If we are providing knowledge and experience,
we need to structure that.
And the last one is support.
We all started as novices.
Everything we do is an approximation of sophistication.
We should expect it to change over time. We have to support that.
The support may come in asking people questions,
giving them a sheet of paper that has an organizational chart on it
or has some guiding images,
but we need to support it.
Now, the final piece of this, the take-home message
from a working memory capacity standpoint is this:
what we process, we learn.
If we're not processing life, we're not living it.
Live life. Thank you.
(Applause)